- What is the focus
that I should have
to start my own company?
What can I learn now?
- What do you think you're best at?
- Sales.
- More of that.
Always, always.
- It's that simple, huh?
- It's that simple.
It's that simple
because people aren't hardwired
to not focus on their weaknesses
and the world is good at
selling to people's weaknesses.
So you're hearing all these
other things to work on
when the real unlock is to
just fucking be the best
at the thing you're
naturally good at.
And then over time,
because you won,
'cause you went all in,
you surround yourself
with the other bullshit.
And when sales,
when you're lucky enough,
being good at sales is
like being born beautiful.
It is, it is a home run.
It's a home run.
Being good at sales is one of
the great gifts one can have
'cause you're always self-sustaining.
Go more into that.
Become better at it.